the United States is really big on
politicians failing upwards we've known
this forever and coming from California
I watched Gavin do some Ruin San
Francisco San Francisco used to be a
really beautiful city when I was a kid
and he ruined it he destroyed it and
instead of going hey that guy really
ruined one of our coolest cities in the
state let's get rid of him we said let's
make him the governor of the state and
so we can have a poo maps for the all of
California and next who knows maybe the
maybe the country maybe the world maybe
the world why stop there Mars well there
there's a uh there was an article
written several years a that I had
Covered California is 5 years ahead of
the United States uh over the past
several decades whatever happens in
California five years later is National
and so they talk about a bunch of
policies you know uh gay marriage was a
big issue in California things like that
uh illegal immigration Sanctuary cities
became Sanctuary States for Sanctuary
state for Trans kids well California had
Sanctuary cities which then turned into
a sanctuary State and then all of a
sudden you start seeing it spread across
the country